foreign
I've talked to besides like my first
boyfriend and the lawyer I don't even
I really haven't had many guys
oh wait I'm trying to think
I talked to a trainer we talked about
that last night yeah what was the
question again could I could you respect
like so could you could you submit to
him yeah because I respect him I'm gonna
submit to him that's naturally what I
want to do like I want somebody who's
gonna love him he says he says don't go
don't go out would you would you delete
your Instagram that's my money maker
so if I'm not if I don't care about a
guy's money that means obviously I'm
taking care of like myself and providing
the lifestyle that I want for myself so
I wouldn't delete my money maker now
would you would you go down and
lifestyle for a family
go down in lifestyle what what does that
mean because I provide my own life so
okay so this is this is like often Kevin
Samuels would talk about how women don't
want a husband they want the lifestyle
and you you've kind of agreed with that
a little bit because a lot of people do
want life a lot of people do because
they don't have any earning potential so
and like his point was back in the day
you would work you both would work at
times and you'd have to work twice as
hard just to have children
so it's like you wouldn't you and he
wouldn't make like more money so it
would be like
try not to butcher this too much
sorry Kevin okay but basically okay but
so the whole point is like you don't get
to go on trips you can't go to London
for a week you can't I mean this is
different because you but you see what
I'm saying you don't get to go on trips
you don't get to eat out like even
growing up we even though we're in a one
percent family like I was very much
jealous of some of the lifestyle that
some of my friends lived
um like they would eat out they had
cable like we didn't have cable TV my
parents like I'm honestly we still went
on vacations but we never flew and it's
like a lot of times like women would
rather have the lifestyle than a family
well to me what you're describing sounds
like money management because that's you
make money and the reason that your
family has stayed wealthy is because
they don't eat out every night they're
not taking trips here they're everywhere
they are even though you guys could do
that right it's like that sounds like
just money management too they do they
do now I will say oh yeah but that
sounds like money management that sounds
smart so yeah if you have more kids it
doesn't make sense to go out and spend
300 at Outback when you could buy
groceries right but the whole point is
like let's say you deleted your
Instagram tomorrow you you could
hypothetically get a part-time job make
20 000 a year data guy that makes fifty
thousand dollars a year that's 70k you
could live off of that it just wouldn't
be the lifestyle you'd want yeah and so
that's that's the whole question is like
would you go down and lifestyle for a
family because you get a family out of
it and that's like Legacy that's like
what we all want
yeah uh it's like a lot of times as
women we don't want to give up you know
the the Nail's done the hair done the
makeup yeah all of that you know
um my answer is gonna be no because
that's something I can provide for
myself so I would never downgrade My
Lifestyle because again I'm not asking a
man to provide something I can't provide
for myself so again I feel like I'm very
I've gotten so much better at money
management not spending 600 at Sephora
you know what I mean I feel like there's
because I have a son now because I have
to think of money
um and be a lot smarter I have
downgraded My Lifestyle already so to go
from this six figures a year to 20 000
doesn't even make sense like I want to
tap into my fullest potential me tapping
in my fullest potential does not entail
working twenty thousand working a twenty
thousand dollar a year job it just
doesn't that's not what I'm here to do I
wouldn't be given this platform I
wouldn't be given this voice if I was if
I was meant to have a twenty thousand
dollar a year job that's just what it is
like and I'm just speaking for me like
I'm meant to do this so I just can't
relate to that now
do you think it's possible to find
traditional women in today's world
traditional no no you don't exist uh I
want to go looking for one I would say
yeah I'm gonna say no let me know in the
comments where do you find them yeah I
feel like they would probably have to be
like super maybe super religious
sorry I'm not trying to I'm only reading
the question yeah yeah so but no I I
don't what is your ideal man now
foreign
I'm still figuring that out I feel like
there's like like kind of how we were
talking about off camera as well
I have not liked what I've been
attracting
so I'm going into my inner world and
right moving some things around
addressing some [ __ ] answering questions
like even this I don't know I don't know
what to tell you right now there are
things that Within Myself that require
more attention than like what do I want
in a guy like I'm art like this is my
thought process I'm already looking at a
small percentage of men so why am I
gonna dedicate
ideally what I would want in a guy
I'd rather just keep it open like if I
go to the mall and say I want a red
bottom with spiked heel and it has a
pink bow and it has to have this I go to
the mall and there's nowhere to be found
what if I just say I'm gonna black shoe
there's a lot of shoes that are gonna
come to me right that I actually like
you know what I didn't even know that I
actually like this one better than the
idea of that so that's why I don't have
my list I'm just really big about the
Mufasa energy again what we're talking
about is masculine energy when I say
Mufasa
um he sees my value he wants to
understand me for me and he's honest
those are the only things that I can
think of off the top of my head
character-wise I were talking about so I
don't know what that man looks like he
could be a nerdy whatever guy if he has
those things what if he's gonna what if
he's got Mufasa energy but a beer belly
I don't [ __ ] with him you can Overlook
the beer belly I could if he had
everything else I mean like I said
ideally you do want a guy that's in
shape like we talked about earlier in
this conversation yeah but if he had
like all of that he had everything I
wanted just a little bit of your belly
we'll go to the gym someone said I'll be
a stepdad if she can make me good food
can you cook
can I cook
and can you can you can you learn if not
I can read instructions you're
directions
where should I take Brittany on a date
where yeah oh like yeah if you were to
go if you were to go on a date where
would you go
I would love to just go on a walk I love
going on walks I go on walks with my dog
I love being outside anywhere in nature
would be an ideal date for me we could
have like a picnic I don't know that'd
be fun
do you do you still post thirst traps so
that's are you still thirst trapping
um
I I haven't looked no not really I've
been posting more about my leggings
um and then I do more of like the car
rants
um
no because it's kind of like
okay people actually would prefer to
hear me and I know maybe the guys would
disagree obviously but I get more
engagement on me speaking than me
showing my ass well I was just wondering
if that's changed since like you became
a mom
I don't know if it's necessarily because
I became a mom I just when I started
speaking a lot more people were just
very interested for whatever reason like
it could be because I sounded [ __ ]
delusional whatever or because I was
making sense to some people
um but I just started to notice people
were wanting to hear me talk more even
when I if you go to my page I have
videos where I'm working out people want
to hear me talk I have over a million
views on every video I'm talking in so I
just give people what I feel like they
would like so thirst driving doesn't
have the same potency as it once did
years ago so that's why I don't do it as
much it's just pointless yeah in my
opinion unless you are trying to like
promote an only fans that's what makes
sense but like I don't have that so like
why am I giving out that I'm gonna just
be in the car talking [ __ ]
do do you regret doing your book
now
it scared away the people that were not
for me anyways
um it helped my book helped a lot of
people and it also most importantly it
helped me because I have lived with
shame my entire life
the book helped release some of that but
I think even yesterday when we talked
about some stuff some more shame came up
right so this is like a layer by layer
thing that I've been dealing with my
whole life
so I I don't regret it it was a big step
I actually fired my manager the day I
posted it because he said you're going
to ruin your life
if you post that book you're going to
lose all your brand deals nobody's gonna
like you
and I've hired them and I'm like well if
it can be destroyed by the truth like if
my truth makes me undesirable
then I would rather just be seen as
undesirable then I don't want to live a
lie and act like I'm some you know this
little princess that's never done
anything I swear that's not my truth so
that's why I'm very big on I accept what
comes behind what I've done because I
don't want to live a lie I don't want to
live a lie I want to be authentic I want
to be myself
take me as I am or have nothing at all
see this is just me thinking out loud I
feel like it could still be the truth
but the truth that you don't tell
everyone you know what I mean yeah
because in my head I'm just like I don't
necessarily like I feel like some guys
would have been even with all this stuff
if everyone didn't have to know yeah
like they would still look past it but
it's like when you put that out there a
good guy that maybe would have taken you
seriously then like wouldn't you know
yeah I mean I feel like because a lot of
times we'll say things like oh if he was
like the right person he would just look
past it but like I'll use myself in this
example so it's not like personal right
but if if there is I think ideally like
when I wanted to wait till I was married
to have sex right and if I if I stayed a
virgin like there are guys that would
have looked at me then that like
wouldn't now because I'm not and a lot
of times like the people's immediately
reaction is like well you could still
find a guy even though you're not ever
okay that's fine that's fine but there's
still a pool of men that like would
probably eliminate me now does that make
sense no I I absolutely understand that
I'm not saying that there weren't like
good guys that may have been interested
yeah um but again this this is my truth
and it's like if the dog my grandma
always used to say if the dog wouldn't
have stopped to [ __ ] he would have
caught the rabbit so it's like I I I
although it's like okay we could
entertain that yeah it just isn't
Progressive for me because again this is
my truth like I have considered like
maybe I don't write another one not
because I'm like I'm so fearful book
number two if you do absolutely yeah
absolutely no and I'm gonna no yeah you
wouldn't be in there because I feel like
even meeting you and having this
conversation and and getting to to pick
Andrew's brain as well like I learned a
lot and that's what I I really pride
myself on is being able to sit down with
anyone and learning and learning from
everyone so that's why I think now I do
view it a little differently I don't
know how I feel about another book
people have been asking for one
I don't know I'm just not I I don't feel
called to do that right now at this
point I'm only support it if I get a
chapter I got
I could do like Pearls of Wisdom I
should talk talk about all the all the
wisdom
you definitely need to use that for your
show Pearls of Wisdom I love that
someone said it should be Eclipse
Channel it should absolutely no yeah and
I was like I was like what should we
make Pearls of Wisdom pearls wins the
merch yeah yeah I would love that that
would be so well I don't know
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible